women that leave men that love their
family and pay for everything because he
steps out and are all hurt they are the
most selfish people on the planet
because they destroy that family they
tear those children apart the father
loses access she steals resources as a
consequence of that selfish women that
leave men okay so yeah so that's a hill
that I'll die on and I know that that's
difficult for women to deal with or
understand um but you missed a little
bit of the context when you sort of open
with that cuz uh
yeah there's something going on there um
women that leave marriages that untie
the knot because he steps out comes back
remains with the family takes care of
everything pays the bills goes to the
events does Thanksgiving does Christmas
all the holidays attends the next
wedding all that good stuff he's still a
part of the family but she's untying the
not because she's hurt because he
cheated yeah there's children involved
in this equation I think it's incredibly
selfish when women and marriages just
over something like that because women
don't seem to understand CU they can't
they can't see the male experience they
just don't have the capacity to do so
because when women cheat they actually
betray there's a big difference between
cheating and betrayal cheating is
stepping out you get your exercise you
come back you're part of that family
unit when women step out they're they're
leaving they're typically going to
another relationship there's no time in
history where we know of women running a
herum of guys multiple guys
simultaneously they're engaged with all
of them it just doesn't exist women are
um serial monogamous they move from one
guy to another guy to another guy right
they're not monogamous in a sense in the
animal kingdom where one of the animals
dies they don't mate again ever they
just move from guy to guy to guy that's
how women generally operate so when
women untie the knot I don't think it's
a good idea I think it's bad for the
children especially especially if
they're small they're young because then
you separate the kids from the the
parents they only get half the time with
one parent and the other half time with
another parent best case scenario worst
case scenario women get 80% of the
custody order so she's getting the kids
most of the time alienating him from his
own kids so that's the point of that I
think it's incredibly selfish and it's a
hill that I'll die
on okay can we ask if if that's one of
those situations where you're thinking
they come back and they don't ever cheat
again or are they like chronically
cheating does it really matter if if
he's taking care of the
family depends I thinkes
matter it's a mental game at that point
because I will say like men usually step
out to cheat because it's physical women
step out and it's emotional and it's
usually it's already like slowly
happening type of things um I'm not a
cheater personally but yeah and that's
the big difference is there's an
emotional connection form between a
woman and a man when she steps out he
can just have some exercise and come
home and forget about it right and that
emotional con connection as part of the
Betrayal which is what women see because
when women step out they know exactly
what they're doing they form an
emotional connection with that man so
she's using that lens to view what he
did with her he can legit go out just
have exercise and come home but they
don't understand that so that's why they
get so upset women get so upset when
it's like oh rich said this why would
you say something like that that's
completely wrong he you know he cheated
on her that's the end of the
relationship is it really is it really
like is that really a good idea to untie
the knot and Destroy children and teach
him a lesson and steal all of his wealth
is it really like is that the way to go
because again I don't see an argument
for
that do you think that the men should be
coming back though once the situation
has been revealed that they should be
coming back
and obviously there's going to be some
sort of damage control right that's
happening now here d control with the
wife as the wife are we just going to
accept it and then move forward and be
like oh what are you going to do what's
the alternative that's the question it's
like let's say there's kids involved I
mean the alternative is is what I mean
breaking up the family it's it's here's
an alternative you now break up the
family you're probably going to get
custody of the kids because that's the
way that it goes about 80% of the time
you're probably going to get alimony
child support half the matrimonial
assets and then what are you going to do
you're going to start dating and you're
going to look for another guy that's not
going to betray you right that's not
going to cheat on you right okay so
maybe you find a guy on a balance of
probabilities and when you're out there
dating and you see um you know these
These Broken women from divorces and
they've got kids in toe and they're
single moms
now if you've got children small
children in your household you'd invite
a man into that household now right
because you've got the matrimonial home
you've got the money you've got the home
you've got the child support
everything's good the kids are are there
80% of the time they're over at Dad's
house every other weekend and Wednesday
night for dinner you're there for your
free weekend you start dating you get
guys over now all of a sudden you're
going to form a new relationship with a
new guy you know what the most what the
greatest threat is to children in a
household small children is a non-blood
relative the vast majority of young
girls and boys too that are violated
come from non-blood relatives so you
thrown the guy out of the house that
loves you that's the father of the kids
to to start new to teach him a lesson
right and now you're inviting a new dude
into the house that could potentially do
something to violate your own
children there's a lot of delist
Downstream sort of effects that that
that come from this decision it's it's a
large decision to make and I don't think
it should be taken lightly just because
you cheated let's have a big freakout
session over it right right are there
caveats and nuances if the husband
returns with a baby an illegitimate baby
or the husband returns with a sexually
transmitted disee sure yeah then then
there's maybe things that you might
contemplate getting upset about women
don't want to be embarrassed they don't
want another woman to come knocking on
the door surprise Anita I've got your
husband's uh child I've got a seed
within me and I'm GNA have this child in
eight months time they don't want to
deal with that
no I've just been question really quick
go ahead J that I just the part that I
don't really like is why does he have to
lie like if he wants does have to lie he
can be honest about it too why can't he
just say babe like just want to have sex
with another woman and then talk about
it and then get the approval or not like
why even that's why the Betrayal comes
into play I I felt betrayed because you
weren't honest with me and I had to find
out because now she's knocking at my
door or he can absolutely be honest
about it too right but do women want to
hear that
narrative they don't because a lot of
people are upon an open relationship
it's not up to him to make that decision
for her well no but they need to talk
together but a lot of people literally
frown upon an open relationship to where
men might fear even bringing that up
because we're going to feel that we're
not worthy enough of it but some people
just kind of have the mindset of like I
want it all type of thing I think
there's a whole bunch of schools of
thought on this right like let's sit
down and have a conversation and let her
know what's happening let's sit down and
have a conversation and ask her for
permission let's not say anything and
just go and do it and if I get caught
just admit to it or let's go out and do
it and if I get caught deny it like
there's all these different schools of
thought and I don't think that there's a
right one or a wrong one it's just it's
difficult it's a difficult conversation
to have I don't think monogamy is very
natural for human beings we struggle at
it men and women struggle at it for
different reasons it can work um but
it's it's a but maintaining long-term
genuine burning desire is very very
difficult as well too it's it's one of
the consequences of men and women having
relationships is you're going to look in
other directions from time to time you
you may exercise where you look in other
directions from time to time I don't
think destroying a family where the man
is committed to the family and his
children and his wife and the household
family events and all that sort of
things is something worth breaking up
the marriage over to potentially put
your kids at risk in the future and
remove them from the father as well uh
children that are raised primarily in a
single mother household Fair far worse
than kids that have good access to both
parents it's it's not good for the kids
it's not good for anybody and it's a
selfish act on the mother's part
generally speaking is my take on it show
of hands by the ladies how many have how
many ladies on the show right now have
been cheated on in the past by a
guy so
everyone so it's so it's pretty
common yeah it's more common than it is
uncommon is it is it really worth
destroying a family and untying the knot
over a guy stepping out but he's so
committed to the family is what I'm
asking because I don't think it is do
you have you say you say that the woman
untying the not is selfish and yet you
don't see the man cheating on his wife
as selfish yeah but the reason why he's
doing it is different from the reason
why women do it when women do it they
have a connection to the guy the first
thing that a woman asks a guy when he
steps out is what did you love her did
you take her to that restaurant that we
go to why did you take her on that
vacation to that to that spot that we've
been to to right like these are the
questions that are asked what are the
questions that men ask a woman when she
steps out did you [__] up how many times
what you guys do together you just
swallow right like they get into very
intimate questions in their head that
are very different from what women are
looking at it's totally different thing
you can't compare the two and say that
it's you know it's it's apples and
oranges I'm sorry but what if she was
cheating because um it's been you know
however many years and now she's bored
so it is just for sex is that it's not
ever just for sex it's not ever just for
sex it's not not how women but that's
not how women have sex women don't have
sex the way that men doesn't exist women
don't women do not they don't have this
they don't have sex the way that men do
they require connection there's there's
this idea that once a woman has stepped
out and because essentially we have if
we want to take this back to an
evolutionary level a woman having sex
with a guy even in the split second that
it takes to happen she has identified
that man as her best option sexually
reproductively etc etc re you know
contraception has only been around for
what 60 70 years or or whatever it is
and so even subconsciously even in that
split moment that woman is identifying
this man as I would have this man's baby
I would let this man impregnate me and
if a woman just was trying to get sex
from a guy why doesn't she just go scre
screw a husband if it's just about sex
whyn't you just screw the guy she's
already with instead of stepping out
because it's not just about sex it's
about way more than that and once she's
had sex with somebody else besides the
husband or besides the boyfriend or who
else that's it she'll never look at him
the same that's what that's what women
fail to understand is they use a lens in
which they view it when they step out on
a guy to apply it to the behavior that
he's using and it's different things
completely and I don't think women are
are able to see it through his eyes it's
entirely possible for a guy to legit go
out step out on a a marriage on his wife
uh come back and think nothing of it
absolutely nothing whatsoever and I
don't think that that is a reason to end
a marriage uh separate the children from
the family and the father and destroy
the family wealth and give it all to
lawyers I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of of other stuff have
an amazing day peace out